prices of energy.
>> This is the island they want to take.
>> Yeah. [music]
>> The Marines aren't even going to get
here before they all
>> Yeah. Th this is uh we're going to have
all of those. And also, we're going to
have a conversation with a guest that
they call Nostradamus. The Nostradamus
of China. Jang Chuchu Chin is going to
be joining us here to talk about what's
going to happen. Remember, he [music]
makes predictions and he's usually
right. Right. He's going to be
predicting what's going to happen in the
future because of what's going on right
now there in the Gulf with China. It's
going to happen with Russia. It's going
to happen with the United States, with
[music] Europe, Asia, all of it on the
Sanchez effect. Let's do this.
By the way, I should mention that our
guest has recently been on with Tucker
and he's been on ABC and he's all he's
all over the place. So, it's really nice
that we're going to be able to be joined
by him in just a little bit. So, hello
again everybody. I'm Rick Sanchez. Let's
get things started. Welcome to the
effect. Donald Trump's approval numbers
are way down, 36%.
So that means only about a third of
Americans think that he's doing a good
job as president. A third. Think about
that. Sometimes it's good to be
simplistic with these things. And more
importantly, it means twothirds of
Americans then don't think he's doing a
good job at all. And it also means that
Mr. Trump is now officially as disliked
as President Biden was. This keeps
happening with American presidents.
There is a consolation. He's doing
better than European leaders. He's doing
better than Mcronone in France. He's
doing better than Starmer,
doing better than Mertz in Germany,
right? Way better. As a matter of fact,
they're way below. And and I should tell
you this too because I think this is
good uh for reference. Mr. Trump began
his presidency around 50% around 47 to
be exact, but somewhere around 50% of
the people in the United States were
okay with him and thought he was going
to be a good president and approved of
him as president at the time. So what's
pushed him down these what 11 points,
right, from 47 to 36?
Well, Americans don't believe that this
war in Iran is being fought for them.
and and what they sense is that the
United States is already losing or
certainly not achieving I its goal of a
quote quick victory which is what they
were told. So, so President President
Trump look
President Trump is not in a good place
right now and he knows that. So what
does he do? What does he do? Does he
back away from this mess that he's
created?
And you know, I mean that he's created
in the Persian Gulf. And does he admit
that this isn't working and is not going
well and hope that somehow he can talk
to Iran and they can acquies
or does he charge forward? Just you know
what? No, the hell with it. Full steam
ahead and let's escalate this war.
Here's where the rubber meets the road.
my sources, people that I have spoken
to, and the information that I have used
to prepare this report for you today as
I bring you this information tells me
it's the latter, not the former. In
other words, he's charging ahead. I am
learning, we are learning that thousands
of US troops, most of them special
forces are already deployed and are
going to be arriving in the Gulf this
weekend,
most likely ready to go. So, let let me
take you through why I'm saying this and
what my sources are telling me and and
and what I have been told from people
that I very much trust, some of which
will remain anonymous, which leads me to
believe to this conclusion that sometime
after the market closes on Friday, after
the market closes, the president of the
United States will announce that US
forces are going to begin an operation
or will have already begun that
operation in the Gulf against Iran.
So, let me take you why I'm coming to
this conclusion. First, and this is
important. If you know the president,
you know that this is a little weird.
The president, Mr. Trump this weekend
was supposed to appear at a fundraiser
in Mara Lago and he was going to be
speaking at this conservative conference
in DT in in in Washington DC CPAC where
he goes every year that appearance has
been cancelled right the the so he's
he's cancelling a fundraiser in Mara
Lago he's cancelling a speech he was
going to give at CPAC this conference in
DC these are two things he usually
doesn't like to do. The president loves
fundraisers. Loves fundraisers and
always has gone to CPAC. Why is he all
of a sudden canceling both of those
things this weekend? Ask yourself,
the expectation is that he's going to
make some sort of announcement after the
market closes on Friday. Now, since
March 12th, according to sources with
direct knowledge, a total of 35,
count them, 35 C17 cargo planes. That's
like the old C130, those big giant cargo
planes where you can get all kinds of
stuff and they go overseas or big tanks
really. Um, they have been taking off
from the United [snorts] States from
bases in Georgia, Kentucky, Tennessee,
and Fort Bragg, California among others.
Yeah, here's a here's a here's a
political story that talks about the
fact that three thou 3,000 troops are
headed to the Middle East. But what they
don't tell you are the specifics of
where they're coming from, how many are
actually there. My sources are telling
me that these 35 cargo ships, planes are
carrying approximately 105 troops. Do
the math. you know, 17 * 105, you're
pretty close somewhere between around
3,500
US soldiers and Marines who are already
there in that theater right now.
Who's going who's being shipped out? Th
this, from what I understand, is not a
contingent of regular troops. This this
contingent that's being sent there is
made up of almost entirely
uh special forces. special forces that
are being sent to this area that will
then uh primarily be members of the 7
75th Ranger Regiment out of Fort
Benning, Georgia, as well as the uh
Marine Expeditionary Units, uh who may
be also the first to arrive. Uh and and
they're going to be joined by members of
the Navy Seal team. Uh they're also
going to be joined by Delta Force and me
members of 82nd Air Force as I reported
to you over the weekend. By the way, by
uh by the way, the reason that we know
this is because many of the men and the
women in these units have said that they
are being deployed. They've said it
themselves. They've either told friends
or told family members. and and they're
going to be joined by the Navy Seal team
members as well who are going to be
there uh coming to this place. Now here
here's the question that needs to be
asked at this point. If this were to
happen, what is going to be the effect?
Uh and where are they going to go? I got
I got I got a map I want to show you
about where this is going to happen.
Let's put up the map if we could of the
two areas where this is most likely to
happen. Look at Car Island. You see that
up there? Because this is where things
got a little fuzzy. But the thinking of
most military analysts who have been
speaking publicly on this issue is that
the elite troops will somehow be dropped
into the theater likely right there at
Car Island off the coast of Iran. and
they're going to be dropped off there
using fly low-flying aircraft, most
likely helicopters to seize Iran's oil.
Now, let me show you another
possibility. There's also thinking that
they will actually use Kimm Island. You
see that right there, Kimm Island?
Analysts say that the troops will
possibly go to Kissim Island, which is
right near the straight of Hormuz, and
then they'll turn that into like an FOB,
right? A forward operating base. You can
see it right there on the map. It's that
little strip of land right between the D
in Casim Island and the S in Straight of
Hormuz. See that right there? That's
Casim Island. By the way, this place is
considered one of the most beautiful
places on Earth. So much so, it's been
designated by UNESCO as a global
heritage site because of its shoreline,
cliffs, and salt mines, and historic
thousand-year-old sites. The population
is roughly about oh a h 100red,000
people who live there that's about to be
taken over. Now let me take you through
the next part. What's the problem for
the US troops if they go in there? The
problem is that Iran has been preparing
for this attack for more than a decade
and they're said to have rocket
launchers and drones that are hidden
along the shoreline where the Persian
Gulf in go. In fact, you know, let's do
this. Uh, Jean, put the map back up. I
want to show them something. Put the map
back up that we were just showing. Okay.
So, you see where Casim Island is and
you see where Car Island is. What do you
see just above that? What is that along
the shoreline? Those are mountains. You
see those mountains? Those mountains
are, according to reports, filled with
hidden rockets, rocket launchers,
drones, and everything that the Iranians
have been hoping or thinking that they
would have to use against some enemy at
some point. And many of them are hiding
underground, hiding underground for this
exact purpose. Now, imagine being one of
those uh Marines of the expeditionary
unit who may be the first to go in or
the rangers coming into this area and
you're being you're being fired on from
these rockets and drones that many of
these guys don't have experience dealing
with like perhaps the Ukrainians do or
the Russians do since they've been in a
drone warfare for some time. So, it it
changes the game and it makes people
wonder what what's going to happen. Is
this too dangerous? Is this is this too
risky is what people are asking. As a
matter of fact, I asked Scott Ritter
about this the other day when he was
right here and I took him over to the
map and and he shows us why he thinks
that this is not going to turn out well
for these elite forces being sent into
Iran. Watch
the ships come in this way. Go right
around that tip. Move it. To come out,
they have to come up and they actually
sail between two Iranian controlled
islands. That's the only exit channel.
So, you're going right between two
islands where they have the missiles on
them. See that coastline there?
>> Yeah.
>> Those are mountains. If you take a look
at the uh the video as the ships go by,
the mountains, everything's dug in right
here. There's a brigade here called the
RF brigade. Four battalions that they're
not ships. They have the missiles.
They've been training for 20 years to
defend this straight. Um we're not now.
We're going to come in with four
amphibious ships,
>> right?
>> All right. As they come in, they won't
make it past here. They'll get sunk
here. get sunk here. We knew this in
2018.
>> They'll get sunk here because of the
>> because of the other missiles. And we
knew this in 2019. The comedant of the
Marine Corps, General Burgerer, issued
the comedant's uh guidance and he said,
"We can't fight this war anymore. We put
all our Marines on one ship and as we
get close in, we're going to get sunk.
So, we're not even going to This is the
island they want to take."
>> Yeah.
>> The Marines aren't even going to get
here before they all die.
>> I don't know. Maybe they were watching
this report because the the
understanding that I have now from some
of the sources that I reached out to
last night are that it's not going to be
a marine operation. In other words,
they're not going to come in through
sea. They're going to come in through
air. Again, the expectation is, and none
of this is confirmed, that they will
come in through with lowflying aircraft,
helicopters,
um, parachuting into these places to get
the troops all in there at once. That's
that's the desire, that's the hope,
that's the expectation. Meanwhile,
there's another part of the story which
is important. The Israeli government is
cheering Mr. Trump on and quite
literally lecturing anyone who will
criticize it at this point. This is kind
of interesting. I want to show you
something. This is the former Israeli
prime minister. His name is Naftali
Bennett. He he convinces some would say
frightens Americans into fighting for
Israel while at the same time
criticizing Europeans for not thanking
Israel enough for what it's doing for
them.
You got to watch this with your own eyes
to actually believe what this guy's
saying here. Take a listen.
Had we not acted, all of Europe would be
under a a terrible nuclear ballistic
missile menace. So, we're fighting your
war and we expect not to be um you know
criticized in an but we expect your
backing. That would be the decent thing
to do. I think any European leader who
sort of says this isn't our problem. So,
when will it become your problem? when
they have a nuclear weapon, when the
missile is on its way to Madrid, when it
hits Madrid or Barcelona, is that when
you're going to wake up? So, we're doing
the fighting. We didn't ask you for any
help, nothing. All we're doing is
fighting against this horrible radical
Islamist menace. We're reducing and
hopefully eliminating this threat. And
instead of thanking us, you're
criticizing us.
>> I like the way he says we're doing the
fighting. Maybe he has a pee in his
pocket or something. Cuz last time I
checked, it's the United States. It's
the United States of America that's
doing the fighting. It's the Americans
who are doing the fighting in Syria, in
uh Iraq, in Afghanistan, in Libya, for
Israel, while this clown sits there and
says, "We're doing all the fighting."
That's just wrong, by the way. It's just
wrong. He shouldn't say that. I I I
think one one of my, you know, one of my
favorite sayings, one that I learned
from my golf buddy and uh a guy who
happens to be a Marine. His name is Mark
Darrow. And uh he lives in Atlanta when
I used to work at CNN. We used to play
golf on weekends. And and it's probably
the most appropriate thing you could say
to somebody right here. And I'd say this
to Mr. Bennett, "Stop pissing on my leg
and telling me it's raining. Stop
pissing on my leg and telling me it's
raining." Because that's what he's
doing. By the way, Mr. Bennett, that guy
you just saw right there, the Israeli
former prime minister, that's the same
guy who recently suggested that right
after the US troops are done in Iran,
Israel will then instruct them to go
into Turkey.
He said it. You remember I played it for
you about 3 weeks ago?
Yeah, he actually said Turkey is next.
I mean anyway so all of this seems to be
coming to a boil and joining me live as
promised is Jang Chu Ching. He is uh a
Chinese educator who happens to be by
the way and I think this is really
important uh known as the Nostradamus
of China because he's really good at
making predictions has made predictions
many many times has his own YouTube
channel and is followed by uh by by by
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of people by the way he was just on with
my friend Tucker Carlson and uh gave a
great interview Um,
Mr. Jen, thanks so much for joining us,
sir.
>> Thanks for inviting me, Rick. So, um, I
guess I I need to ask you first and
foremost
how you would predict predict this
assault this weekend that seems to be
forthcoming. Uh, how do you think this
would turn out if it actually takes
place? Well,
well, as you laid out, every military
analyst will tell you a ground invasion
of um Iran with only a few thousand
Marines and possibly a few thousand
um airborne soldiers, uh Rangers will
will be a disaster. Unfortunately,
Donald Trump um is a reality television
star, and so what he's interested in is
not strategy, but optics. He wants to
create a narrative that the Americans
are winning this war because right now
the whole world thinks that America is
losing this war. So he wants to with one
knockout punch basically decapitate the
Iranian regime. And so um I don't think
he's interested in a long drawn out
ground invasion which could take months
or years. He's hoping to settle this
over the weekend which is what happened
with Venezuela, right? remember
>> um January 3rd, Del Force swept into
Caracus and um abducted a Maduro and the
war was over in only a few hours. So in
Trump's mind, he believes that if he can
pull off another great television
spectacle, this war will be over and
then he can um be the winner of this
war. Well, I'm hoping that my Chevrolet
becomes a Rolls-Royce, but that doesn't
mean it's going to happen. So,
obviously, my question to you is that's
what he hopes will happen.
What do you think is more likely to
happen after this assault this weekend?
So right now we don't know how this
assault will take place, but we have to
remember that the US military um is very
deadly and very efficient with these
quick strikes. So we're going to imagine
that if it happens this weekend, uh
there will be a bombardment of the coast
to knock out um Iranian air defenses and
then the Marines and the U 82nd Airborne
Division will swoop into place. Now, um,
analysts believe that this they were
talking to either Car Island or as you
mentioned Casim Island or maybe even a
NATO naval base near the coastline, but
it's entirely possible that they were
target all three all at once. It would
be a multi- vector assault almost like
D-Day. Um, because that very much is
what Trump wants. He wants fireworks. He
wants um good television. He wants to
control the the narrative.
>> Yeah.
But if he tries to control the narrative
by maybe landing people on those beach
heads, I was listening to you when you
were explaining to Tucker during your
interview with him that in many ways
this is the way Vietnam started. First
you go in just to do a wrap-up and
before you know it, the whole thing gets
out of control and now you've got a
hornets nest that's been disturbed.
>> Is that right?
>> Right. So yeah, the great fear is that
Trump is actually using this first
strike in order to rally public opinion
to just justify an actual draft and a
full-scale ground invasion of um Iran.
So right now Trump does not have the
public support and the congressional
approval for a full-scale ground
invasion. So most experts believe you
need at least half a million troops to
invade Iran. There's no way he's getting
half a million troops. There's no way
he's getting $20 billion in
congressional funding for this war. So
he basically needs to create um a
narrative um an excuse maybe a false
flag to rally American sentiment. Right?
So if the Marines go in and there are
two possibilities either they take Car
Island and they're very successful in
which case um everyone believes that
this war can be won or the Marines get
slaughtered in which case American
patriotism takes over and they want
revenge for what happened. So I think
that is really the play not that they
think that this first strike this um
will will decapitate the regime or force
to surrender. What they're really trying
to do is draw America into a long war of
attrition with Iran.
>> So you and I are just talking about what
the United States wants to do. Now let
me ask you from the other side. Let's
look at it as if we were Iran. Iran is
going to say as soon as we know that
you're doing this, yes, we're going to
attack you, but beyond attacking you,
we're going to do everything possible.
You think the uh Straight of Hormuz is
closed now? Wait till you see what we're
going to do to make sure it's going to
be closed for a long time as a result of
what you're doing now. And we're going
to hit the desalination plants in all of
the GCC or uh as the Iranians want to
call it, the PGCC countries. Um and this
is just going to be a I guess a a
potential disaster zone to hear them
tell it. What do you make of that
description that they seem to be uh
threatening us with?
Well, I mean the reality is that America
right now is in a quagmire in Iran. They
America doesn't really have good
military options because right now Iran
is holding the global economy hostage as
you point out. Iran has a lot of
strategic flexibility, right? it can
choose to mine the sham moves completely
close off the shoo has not done so yet
and it can choose to target uh the GC
countries uh their energy infrastructure
and their desalination plants. So the
great fear among Americans is that the
price of oil shoots up to $200 a barrel
which will just devastate the global
economy uh which would turn public
opinion in the United States and and
around the world against Trump. So Trump
is really desperate right now. The same
time he's surrounded by advisers, people
like Peter Hexf, Marco Rubio, um Jared
Kushner, Steve Wickoff, who are
Warhawks. They they've been lying to him
all this time. Um and so they will
encourage him and make him believe that
a quick strike will resolve a lot of
issues. Uh Trump knows he's in a
desperate situation and so he's going to
make a desperate play even though as you
point out it it will probably not work
out and it doesn't make any strategic
sense.
>> Let me show you uh something that you
were just talking about. This is uh the
leader of the Philippines declaring a
state of emergency because his comp his
country is running out of fuel. Take
this Gene. I think it's cut three.
>> It's an emergency of the energy sector.
the supply of energy and the prices of
energy.
>> President Ferdinand Marcos Jr. saying,
"We're declaring a state of emergency in
the Philippines." I'm hearing similar
situations in Thailand, in uh Vietnam.
What What does this portend? What does
this portend Jen?
Sorry, Rick, but I I hate to break the
news, but this is CO 2.0. Southeast
Asia, India, Japan, South Korea, all
these places are going to have to go
into energy lockdowns. They're going to
have to do work from home. They're going
to have to ration gas. Um, this is the
reality because the world was the world
economy was built to be efficient,
not resilient. For many years, um,
people became addicted to access to
cheap energy. And even if there were a
ceasefire announced tomorrow, experts
say it's going to take a few more weeks
um maybe even many more months before
the GCC can restore um uh energy
production to a level before this war
sorted out. So the world economy is in a
really bad place and especially places
like um Southeast Asia uh especially
Thailand, Vietnam, Philippines, they
should brace for the worst case
scenario. And so what I'm hearing you
say, and it I think we should probably
go through this again. I want to make
sure that I'm hearing you correctly.
You're saying we're already at a point
of almost no return. And if this thing
escalates to the point where what we
just described that could happen this
weekend really blows up uh by both
sides, we will be at a point of no
return for the global economy. Is that
what you're saying?
>> Right. That's exactly what I'm saying.
And Southeast Asia is really the canary
in the in the um coal mine because
Southeast Asia uh India and Japan and
China get a lot of its oil from the GCC.
It gets most of its oil from the GCC. So
we should see the pain uh first take
place in Thailand, Vietnam, the
Philippines, and then it's going to
cascade across the world. Now you you
you predict things and you look at the
future and I think the way you're
describing the future is that we will
all live in a world where we're just
going to have to get used to this. And
you're not talking about 6 months down
the road. You're talking about the
future of the planet is that we're
literally going to be in almost a new
normal situation as a result of what
we're seeing taking place in the Gulf. I
think that's kind of what I heard you
say the other day. Is that correct? And
if not, please clear it up.
>> Right. So my argument is that the
unipolar moment when America hijgemony
was dominant throughout the world that
was really unsustainable. It created the
world that we live in for the past 20
years when it was really cheap to fly
around the world. Uh when you could go
to supermarket and and have any food
from around the world all four seasons.
um when any middle class individual
could live the lifestyle of a Roman
emperor. So we've had we've been extreme
extremely blessed these past 20 uh 30
years in the American unipolar moment
but it was not sustainable because it
relied on the exploitation of certain
areas of the world mainly the developing
world um and it created a lot of
corruption inequality um and it strained
the global resources and so we're seeing
a collapse of this unipolar moment and
now nations have to adapt to a
multipolar world and that often means I
I think uh to a focus on
de-industrialization
where they move people from the cities
which are energy dependent uh they
depend on uh energy imports and back to
the countryside to focus more on
agricultural um uh work.
>> Let's talk about this region by region
and country by country because I want to
get your take on what's going to happen.
So let's start like right at the heart
of the situation and that is Iran
itself. What what what do you think will
come of Iran as a result of this
conflict where they seem according to
most military experts I talked to to be
either winning or at least in a draw
right now with the United States. But
what happens to Iran long term after
this?
I happen to believe that Iran is winning
this war strategically, meaning that
they have certain military objectives
going into this war and they have
achieved all these military objectives
including uh controlling the sh of
hummus and forcing nations to pay tolls
um in order to access the humus,
including threatening the GCC nations to
the point where uh Qatar and Oman are
now siding with the Iranians, um
destroying American military bases
throughout the Middle East containing
and disciplining and basically teaching
Israel a lesson. So in terms of
strategic objectives, Iran is doing a a
wonderful job. But the reality is that
Iran is still up against two military
superpowers, America and Israel, and
they are destroying the nation. Um and
we can expect that as um Israel and
America continue lose this war
strategically, they will become more
desperate. meaning that they will target
uh strategically uh Iran's civilian
infrastructure, power plants, reservoirs
to make life very difficult for the
Iranians. So we should expect massive
destruction in Iran as this war
continues and m much of the population
will uh face tremendous hardship. At the
same time,
>> what this war is doing is rallying the
patriotism, national pride of the
Iranian people, is unifying the people.
And also, regardless of what happens,
the Iranians are going to maintain
control over the ship of Humus
>> and that is a major maritime choke point
that will allow Iran to generate
billions of dollars in revenues every
year,
>> aren't they?
>> And at the end of at the end of
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Finish, please. I'm
sorry. I thought you were done. Please
finish your point.
>> And I think we may have lost, but he'll
probably come back. Let's Let's
>> Let's hold on. Yeah.
>> Sorry. Go ahead. Go ahead, Jen. Finish.
I
>> You're back.
>> Yeah. So, we also have to remember that
Russia and China are strong allies of
Iran. So Iran is a pivot point for
Russia's north south corridor and Iran
is also a pivot point for China's one
belt and road initiative. So it is in
the best interest to help Iran um
rebuild as as soon as possible um um
once this war is over. So with the
financial and industrial assistance of
China and Russia and with the control of
state of Humus then we we can expect
Iran to come back much more powerful
than before. In many ways um Iran will
come out a major winner of this war.
>> Wow. In the long run. In the long run.
>> In the long run. Yes.
>> Then let's move to the uh other dcc
countries. Let's talk about UAE and Oman
and Saudi Arabia and all of the Kuwait
and all of these Qatar and all of these
countries. Uh what happens to them? They
they must feel right like they were
promised protection but they haven't
really gotten it. And I talked to my
sources in these countries and I get a
sense they're very concerned for their
own future right now. What happens in
that part of the world?
Right. So you could argue the GCC is
really the main pivot of the American
empire. Meaning that uh the GCC sold its
oil in petro dollars u making the US
dollar the global reserve currency and
then it would take uh its profits and
then recycle it back into the American
economy mainly into the stock market
mainly into AI investment. And right now
most of the global most of the American
economy is run on AI investment. So if
the GCC were forced to withdraw its
investments from America and focus more
on its own national development and
national defense, then America would
suffer economically tremendously. The GC
longterm has a lot of issues. It doesn't
really have a military defense strategy.
It was too reliant on the Americans. So
once the Americans leave the scene and
these TGC nations will have to either
depend on Israel or Iran for protection,
maybe nations like Qatar and Oman will
choose to side with the Iranians. Um
Saudi Arabia, uh UAE will side with the
um Israelis. But the future for the GC
is not optimistic because remember for
the longest time they were a mirage,
meaning that they were not e
economically viable entities. They
didn't have access to fresh water. They
didn't have access to agriculture. And
they didn't have that much human
capital. They were entirely reliant on
expatriots
for expertise. And now that this u
mirage has shattered, these expatriots
are going to go home and they're going
to have to spend a lot of their
resources on defense. And so long-term
prospects for the GCC is very, very bad.
>> Who are the biggest winners in all of
this? not just now but looking forward
uh maybe a few years as this thing
continues to develop.
>> Well, the two biggest winners right now
in the long term are Israel and Russia.
>> Um Israel once America leaves SENCOM um
will be absorbed into Israel. So all
these military bases um all this um
aerosy the Americans have will be
absorbed into Israel. Once America
leaves uh then Israel will automatically
achieve its greater Israel project
because um it will be able to control uh
the the GCC and this has been a
long-term ambition of the Israelis for
many decades especially these religious
fanatics now that now control the
Israeli state. Um so and also we have to
remember that Israel um has always been
the uh strategic hub and pivot of global
trade. It will continue continue to be
so even after this war is over. So
expect Israel to thrive and flourish
after this war is done as global
investment um re goes to Israel in order
to rebuild um the Middle East and create
the greater Israel project. Can I just
stop you there? Can I just stop Can I
Can I just stop you right there with
Israel because there are people watching
us obviously we have tens of millions if
not 30 million viewers are going to be
watching you say that and they're
thinking in their mind as they're Yeah.
But c can they achieve that while they
admit themselves because I've talked to
Israeli officials who say we understand
that right now we're the most hated
people in the world. Can they achieve
that despite the antagonism, the global
antagonism against this very small
country?
Right. Um, so that's a very good point.
So after this war, I expect that Israel
and Iran will come to a trade deal, come
to an agreement. And then what's going
to happen is that after this war is
over, anti-semitism is going to rage
across the world because Americans will
rightly believe that Israel was
responsible for the downfall of American
empire. So you have not just Jewish
talent returning to Israel but also a
lot of global capital um going to to to
Israel. Also, from the Israeli
perspective, they really don't care if
the world hates them because they have
Mossad. Mossad is very good at
infiltrating and subverting resistance
movements.
>> And so they so if anyone opposes them,
then Mossad will take care of them. And
that is what they believe they must do
because in the Jewish esquetology, in
their in the fanatical Jewish
understanding of things, they believe
that the world will always hate them.
And so they need to prepare for the day
when the world um uh unites against
them. So um unfortunately you have these
fanatics in power who are very
fatalistic and who actually believe that
um anti-semitism the growth of
anti-ismitism
u the growth of global hatred against
Israel it will actually benefit Israel
in the long term because it will unify
the Jewish people and make them more
reliant on God. the Jewish people will
learn redemption
um and repetitence and this will allow
God Yahweh their God to uh support them
in the final uh war between Israel and
the world.
>> That's disheartening to hear you even
say it. You mentioned two countries. You
describe Israel's situation. You said
there was a second country that was the
real winner in all of this. Who's that?
Well, um, Russia is really benefiting
from this war because, um, as Iran
attacks the global economy, United
States has no choice but to, uh, reduce
sanctions on Russian oil. So, the
Russian economy will benefit tre
tremendously from this war. Also um with
the United States out of the Middle East
uh we can expect the United States to be
forced out of the Middle East uh as this
war drags on. Then Russia and Iran can
build a closer trade partnership
establishing a north south uh corridor
which will then allow Russia to access
Africa, the Middle East uh and and Asia
through Iran. And um Russia will
eventually win this war in Ukraine.
Russia won this war two years ago. I
don't understand why the Ukrainians are
still resisting. But once this war is
over, Russia will have control over
onethird of the world's carbohydrates
and most of this uh food will be
destined for the Middle East and Africa.
>> What about I'm I'm just curious the
United States relationship with Russia.
It's like on again, off again. It was
horrible during Biden, bad during Obama,
kind of neutral during Trump. And there
seems to be out there this glimmer of
hope that somehow the Russians and the
Americans will finally be able to pull
it back together. Do you see that in the
foreseeable future?
So right now there's a civil war in
Washington DC between those global
globalists uh um Atlanticist who have a
racist hatred of Russia. for whatever
reason they believe that Russia is
demonic and they must destroy Russia.
And so these people will always hate
Russia. But now you you have a new group
of people uh MAGA America first people
like uh Donald Trump and uh JD Vance who
believe that uh Europe Asia is not in
the American best interest. America
should just focus on the Western
Hemisphere and these people are
perfectly happy to come to terms with
Russia. I believe strongly that at the
end of the day, America first MAGA will
win the foreign policy debate and
eventually America and Russia will come
to terms.
>> A year, two years somewhere down the
road, any sense of time on that?
>> We are looking at at the earliest maybe
10 years. And the reason why is that
this transatlantic alliance uh between
these um people hate Russia in Europe
and America, they're intent on sending
NATO into Ukraine to fight Russia. So
Europe will call up a draft eventually
and then they will mass a conscription
army to fight against Russia in the
trenches of Ukraine. I think this is
suicidal. I think this is kind of
productive. I think that ultimately this
will destroy Europe. But for a reason,
NATO is committed to a final battle with
Russia in Ukraine.
>> What is that reason? Why would they want
to do that? It, you're right, it sounds
suicidal.
>> Well, there are lots of reasons we could
look at. One possibility is this
ingrained hatred of anything Russian in
the European psyche that goes back to
the Cold War and maybe even before
before then. But there's a deep se deep
deep-seated irrational hatred of Russia
among the European elite. That's one
possibility. Another possibility is that
um there's a some cause fallacy in that
Europe has invested too much resources
into this war in Ukraine. It's like a
gambler in a casino who's lost a lot of
money and who cannot leave the casino
because he doesn't want to go home and
be cursed at by his wife for the rest of
his life. Right? So they're kind of
stuck some cost fallacy. Another reason
is that internally Europe is suffering a
lot of issues. It suff it it faces the
cost possibility of economic collapse uh
because it lost access to cheap uh
Russian energy. Um it's also possible
you have a civil war in Europe because
you have millions of these Muslim uh
migrants who've come into the country
and the local population feel
threatened. And so there's this
right-wing backlash in Europe. So maybe
to avert a civil war, maybe it's better
off to send these men to die die die in
the trenches of uh Ukraine. Wow. Okay. U
another country that is the West is
often antagonistic to is uh China. You
obviously know a lot about China. Let me
show you some headlines I've been
looking at in just the last couple of
days that I had our team pull for you.
These are headlines uh that mostly are
being generated from the West. There's
the Wall Street Journal. Trump's
ambivalence on Taiwan opens a historic
opportunity for China. Taiwan is wary of
China exploiting the Iran war. PLA vows
stronger combat readiness against Tai.
So, you see, you see what the message is
here, right? All these articles that are
coming out of the West is it's just a
matter of time now. Any moment now,
China is going to invade Taiwan and take
it over and we all need to be very
concerned. And Trump is dropping the
ball. He's using all our forces over
here, but he should be looking over
there. That's kind of the message that's
coming out of that. What do you make of
that message and what is the truth?
Well, I think before the possibility of
an invasion of Taiwan was very low and
now because of what's happening in Iran,
uh that possibility has almost gone to
zero. So, let me explain my reasoning.
Um first of all um China is very
dependent on oil from the GCC. The GCC
provides 40% of oil for China.
>> And if you have if you don't have access
to this oil, how are you going to fight
a war, right? You're better off just uh
maintaining your economy. That's number
one. Number two is
um this war has shown the possibilities
of asymmetric warfare where you know the
United States had uh super carriers
Abraham Lincoln Gerald Ford it had the
world's best air defense
>> it had um the best jet fighter planes
like the F-35 and all this technology
all like these big weapon systems are
proving futile against a um dog
resistance among the Iranian people.
>> Yeah.
>> And so does China also want to find
itself in a similar situation in Taiwan?
Um and also what we're seeing is that
this humiliation
um of the American military in Iran is
going to have global consequences
meaning this is really the end of the
American empire. uh it's really
punctured the aura of inevitability and
invincibility on which the American
empire really um rested right people now
understand how to fight the American
empire and and the American empire is a
paper tiger so China doesn't want to
take this risk with Taiwan as well
especially with a um uh emerging Japan
okay and the third thing is that this
war in the uh Middle East if you don't
make North Korea South Korea IA and
Japan much more militaristic, much more
nationalistic because they recognize
that uh America can no longer protect
global peace. And so they need to rearm
as soon as possible in order to defend u
their trade routes. And so I think that
as a Chinese strategist, I would look
more at Japan than I would look at
Taiwan.
>> Really? Well, you know, you know, I've
mentioned this on this uh newscast a
couple of times that I've been watching
the THAAD missile system supposed to be
the most incredible and sophisticated
system in the world. It's not same as
the Patriot system. I talked to Ted
Postal and he came on my show and said
that these two systems together are only
knocking down maybe 5% of the rockets
and the missiles coming in. I'm thinking
if I'm Japan or if I'm South Korea, I'm
watching this and I'm saying, "Wait a
minute. These are the systems you told
us that you've put in our country so we
can defend ourselves. If they're not
working there, they're not going to work
for us." That might be impetus for them
to go out and say the hell with it.
We're going to defend ourselves, right?
How far do they go, though? Do they go
as far as ballistic missiles? Do they
even go as heaven forbid nukes?
>> Right. So I think if you're Japan uh
your main focus is on reasserting naval
supremacy in uh the south south China
sea.
>> Yeah.
>> Um the reason why is that Japan is
entirely dependent on uh imports for its
resources especially oil and food and so
it needs to protect these trade routes.
And so you will see much more aggression
among the Japanese in the South China
Sea. Um especially around the state of
Mala, especially around uh the street of
Taiwan. Uh the South Koreans, North
Koreans will also recognize that they
need to remitize as soon as possible in
order to access resources.
>> I asked you about the bond between or
the potential bond between Russia and
the United States. Let's talk for a
minute about this bond between China and
Russia all of a sudden which see seem to
me anyway when I went to uh cover the
Shanghai summit I got a sense that it's
getting stronger with each passing year
that there is even a special
relationship between Mr. Putin and Mr.
she and that these two countries
together between their resources the re
the hydrocarbons of Russia for example
the the the the skill set of
technologically of the Chinese the
population of the in other words when
when you put this puzzle together it's a
it's a formid for formidable uh
operation between these two countries it
seems to me but you know I'm not you and
you know a lot more about this I'm
wondering what you think of this uh this
alliance and what it bodess for the
future
I think this alliance between Russia and
China will be great for both countries
and already we're seeing you know
millions of Russians coming to China
China for vacation uh to establish
partnerships and so this is fantastic
for both countries. The problem is that
Chinese policy makers tend to be on the
real politic uh the realism school of
geopolitics meaning that um they really
don't see it's in the best interest of
China to rely solely on Russia because
as this war in the Middle East develops
then China will rely more on more and
more on Russian energy and from a
Chinese geopolitical perspective that
can be dangerous in the long term
because it's possible that um Russian
energy itself takes a hit, right? So, if
you're China, your immediate response to
this war in um the Middle East is to
establish as many energy trading
partners as possible. And unfortunately,
that means you have to negotiate with
Americans because um uh North America
can possibly be a major supplier of
energy to China in the future. So I
expect that when Donald Trump does come
to China in midmay then I think that one
thing they will discuss is uh the United
States selling North American energy to
China. Will a US president finally come
along who will understand that the
hegemony has to e has either come to an
end or must come to an end. the the the
chest thumping, you know, American
exceptionalism and all that when the
rest of the world is looking at it and
saying, "Yeah, America's I mean, I'm
American. It's an incredible country
with an incredible economy and and
incredible resources, but it's no longer
the only incredible country that there
are coalitions of other countries that
it's going to have to learn to either
compete with or or or or or deal with.
And my fear is that every president
comes in and does just the opposite,
buries us further into hegemony, which I
don't think is positive, but maybe I'm
wrong. What do you think?
Look, I completely agree with you in
that um if a US president were to learn
to work with other countries, especially
China, Russia, and Iran, the world would
be a much better place. Um the world
benefits more from trading with with
each other than funding each other.
Unfortunately, there are some structural
issues in America that cannot be
addressed in the short term. The first
major structural issue is the dominance
of the military-industrial complex that
thrives on international conflict,
right? So like this this war um even
though America's losing this war, they
will still generate billions in profits.
And that's just how the military complex
works. That's problem number one.
>> Yeah.
>> Problem problem problem number two is
that unfortunately America is controlled
by the baby boomer generation and the
baby baby boomer generation are used to
the unipolar world. They think that it
is their birthight uh to have the
unipolar world and so they cannot
possibly accept um America in decline.
And so if you just look at polling, most
Americans are against this war, but baby
boomers are actually more supportive of
this war than other generations. And I
think that's because the baby boomers
don't really have can't really face any
consequences. America loses this war,
not a big deal. If America wins this
war, then they can still vacation in the
Mediterranean and feel good about
themselves. Okay? So the baby boomers
are a huge problem. And honestly,
they're not dying. Uh they they'll
probably live to 100 on average. And the
third issue is just the mentality of
America's foreign policy elite where
both Democrats and Republicans believe
that America has the right to empire.
America makes the world a better place.
If America were to lose the empire, then
the world would be would go uh into the
garbage can. And so they are determined
um to maintain hijgemony. And this is a
consensus among all Washington uh elite.
>> Yeah. and unfair unfortunately I think
it's a it's it's a dangerous consensus
that leads us in the wrong direction.
Let me finish up with a couple of quick
things. First of all, you're Canadian
which is really interesting because
Canada is a country that I don't think
gets as much attention as it needs and
but it's part of the Americas. When when
we think of America, we always think of
the United States, but the Americas is
Canada. The Americans is is the United
States. The America is Mexico. The
United States is Cuba, the place where I
was born. It's it's that whole uh those
two continents essentially. Um where
does the rest of the Americas fall into
uh especially a place like Canada for
example in in the future in its
relationship with the rest of the world
and of course its relationship with the
hegemony itself the United States and
Washington DC.
Well, as a Canadian um who follows
Canadian politics, I have to say this,
Rick, but Canada does not have a future.
Uh the Trudeau administration and now
the Carney administration are really
destroying Canada.
>> Um they have chosen
easy politically correct policies and
ignore the best interests of the
Canadian people. So these past five, six
years, they've let in millions of
immigrants, and this is causing the the
housing market to explode, meaning
Canadians can longer afford um a to buy
a house. Uh Canadians can no longer find
a decent job. Uh standard living has
gone way up in uh Canada. Then you have
the CO policies that really destroyed
the energy and optimism of the Canadian
people. You know, there were these
trucker protests in Ottawa um during the
the CO lockdowns and all they wanted was
for the voice to be heard and the
Trudeau administration responded by
debanking all the all the truckers and
all those who supported uh their right
to protest. So Canada has Canada has
become extremely author authoritarian
these past few years especially after
the co uh lockdowns and now what Carney
seems to be doing is asset stripping
Canada meaning that he's trying to sell
Canadian land Canadian resources to the
Qataris to the Chinese to the Americans
before Canada itself goes goes bust so
Canada does not have a viable future um
it will it will probably be absorbed
United States at some point So finally,
uh, you've been this is amazing. You're
you're you're expanding my brain
listening to you with all these areas of
the world that you've broken down for
us. Um, let's finish with what we have
at hand, this situation where once again
the United States is asserting itself in
the in in the middle Middle East. And
one can't help but wonder what is your
final fine point as a futurist that we
need to understand about this moment
that we're living in right now that we
will all look back on maybe three, four,
five years from now and say that's when
things changed. And what will that
change be?
>> Well, Mark Carney used a word um during
his uh world economic reformer speech
way back in January. He used the word
rupture. And so we are living in the
world of rupture where old institutions,
old systems of belief um are going to
break down. And not only our values and
institutions are going to break down,
but nation states are going to break
down as well. the global economy will
collapse at some point and nations will
go into revolutions, political
instability, civil war. So this will be
a time of tribulation of chaos. Um but
at the same time it will also be a time
of spiritual awakening in that more and
more people will discover and think to
themselves what gives what gives me
meaning and purpose in life.
>> Am I just a consumer or am I a human
being? And so I think that you will see
a massive growth in religion. You will
see a massive uh resurgence in
spirituality. So this will mark a
turning point in human history. And
looking back maybe 100 years from now,
maybe historians will think this was a
good thing because before we were too
consumeristic, we were too uh
individualistic. We were too selfish and
greedy. And this has led us to a time of
massive depression um and and massive
unhappiness. And so maybe this rupture
is the divine sign that enables us to
fully uh engage in self-reflection and
discover what brings us happiness and um
meaning in our lives.
>> Jang Chu Ching, predictor, futurist,
historian. It's an amazing conversation
to be able to uh watch you capture all
of these issues and show us not only
where we are but kind of where we've
been and also where we're going. Uh do
me a favor, let people know where they
can find you because I think people will
watch you here and say, "I want to hear
this guy some more." Where where can
people find you if they want to uh
listen to some of the things that uh you
speak of?
>> Right. So, the best place to find me is
on YouTube. So I'm a teacher in Beijing
and I upload my lectures to YouTube on
history on uh geopolitics on game theory
and so if you go to predictive history
YouTube then you will find my lectures.
>> Thanks so much. You've been so kind to
give us so much of your time and you're
such a smart guy. Thanks really
appreciate you coming on and I know our
viewers uh appreciate it as well. Thank
you.
>> So wow. Um, I could I could I could have
danced all night. I mean, every single
question I asked him, he had a concise,
explicative, well uh, thought through
answer that wasn't just something that
I've heard others say, but there was a
uniqueness to his tone and to his
intellect, which I so appreciated. I
just felt like I had to say that. Um, I
appreciate everything that you guys say
to me as well. And I know that we get
tens of thousands of comments from you.
So, time to take a closer look at what
you've been saying and many of your
comments following my conversation with
Scott Ritter and Garlet Nixon yesterday.
We start with Sack N1. He says, "Rick,
today's episode of Sanchez Effect was a
big eye openener. It was brilliant.
Thanks to Scott Ritter for decoding and
informing viewers of the ground
realities, the demographics. Simply
brilliant episode. That's very nice.
Makes us feel good. Uh Veny verse some
says Garland is one of the best analysts
out there. A damn shame X has locked his
account. Yeah, damn shame X locks a lot
of people and so do others in social
media. Maybe we can get him to turn that
around. Baker man 58 5811 says,
"Watching you hilarious mopes pretend
this fantasy where Iran is winning is
surprisingly funny, like watching circus
animals perform." Okay, you think we're
wrong? I appreciate your comment. Cool
guy 11 says, "You are 100% wrong.
Nothing about what Iran is doing is
basic. Nothing. everything they're doing
cannot be replicated by 90% of American
engineers. And then uh Derry K. House
says, "I agree with Scott Ritter. The
only problem is that the US will plant
troops there and quickly proceed to use
tactical nuclear weapons on Iran city."
Scott, I hope not. Please. Uh but thank
you for your opinion. And Curin says, "I
have a question. It's not a gotcha. In
the past few weeks, Scott made a
statement that in his experience, it
would take approximately 6 months to
mobilize ground troops and send them to
Iran. Yeah, I remember he said that on
our show. And now it turns out that's
not the case. What is the explanation
for that? Well, let me explain it to
you. What Scott said was taking in
regular troops, right? Not not not not
what we're talking about now. What I
reported to you today is elite forces,
right? Special forces. That's an
operational troop deployment. What Scott
was talking about is sending in 40,
50,000 US troops to essentially invade
uh Iran. Two different scenarios. So,
what he was saying at first is very
different from what is taking place
right now. But I appreciate the
question. It's a good one. Also, these
guys, F sold, pardon me, NM151 says,
"These guys are effing soldiers risking
their lives to bring us the truth." He's
talking about Scott and others. And like
Doug McGregor, for example, it baffles
me that people won't even give a like or
a thumbs up on a streaming platform to
spread the truth, yet they get millions
of views. Well, as always, we appreciate
all the feedback and we want to tell you
that uh much of what you see here, we're
going to be posting. [music] So, you're
going to be able to see it on Bitshoot,
which we now have an association with.
You're going to be able to see it on X.
[music] You're going to be able to
comment. You're going to be able to
listen to it and take me for a jog on
Spotify. I love to go jogging with
podcasts, [music] not my own. Um, but
anyway, most importantly, thanks so much
for being with us and thank you for
letting us into your homes. [music] I'm
Rick Sanchez and we'll be looking for
you next time.
>> [music]
[music]